[Musik]
was die fehler der akademiker bataillon
zur verlegung für die ausfinanzierung
interaktion 20 angetreten
die persönlich ist es super möglichkeit
wieder einmal mit den bakterien im
freien gelände zum üben und die vierte
super dass die weniger wird eine
führungs kenntnisse im rahmen von dieser
übung beweisen können
[Musik]
ich bleibe hier auf die übung und es
wird sich eine große herausforderung für
uns alle mit so einem personen zusammen
zu arbeiten aber wir sagen super
motiviert und das wird zu bewirken
[Musik]
sofort war jetzt große
übung in der größenordnung man nicht
teilgenommen und dementsprechend haben
die erwartungen ja es ist einmal ganz
besonders wie normal war nun ihr zum
bogen in dem ausmaß das ist irgendwie so
kombination aus begeistert dass so viel
vor zeit und so sind aber diese
nervosität sorgen weiß auch neben ganz
was anders ist das internet
[Musik]
16 dieser gewinn soll sein dass wir erst
einmal unser unsere jahresplan
abarbeiten das heißt rückkehr das heißt
angriffs und schied der jahrgänge das
erst in zwei jahren ist das im lehrplan
steht dass wir hier das zusammenfassen
und hier mit folkgruppe enorm
[Musik]